やっぺ
（はぁ）
久しぶりだなキラン（`・ω・')
えーこんにちははじめ社長です
えー長らく
動画をお休みさせて頂きました
はい
やべ言うことない(；ﾟДﾟ)
言うことないしーなんか
言うことはあるんですけど（←どっちやねん）
言えないことのほう多くてあんま言えないんですけど
まあ単的に言うと
まあなぜ僕が東京に来たか
静岡を出て東京に来て
動画を休んだり
結構バタバタしてたんですけど
バタバタしてたものが
ついに
終わりましたぁ！
おつかれぇっす！！
おつおつおつ！！！！
ねぇもほんどしゃべることがない
しゃべることがないんだけども
な・なんかこうわかる？このもどかしいかんじ
喋ることは無い
いや喋るべきだとは思うんすよ
喋るべきだとは思うんですけども
こう皆さんに喋っちゃいけないこととかも多くて
けどそれをなかったことにもできないじゃないですか
そしたらお前なんで休んでたんだよみたいなの
ちょうまく説明はできなんですけど
とりあえず僕ちょっとバタバタしててとても忙しくて
東京に住むぐらい
東京に住むぐらいのことをしなきゃいけないくらい
すごく忙しくて
☆よ☆う☆や☆く☆
（謎の決め顔）
ようやくその、僕がすべきことを
無事終え
やっとちょっと
You Tuberっぽいものに戻れる
気がします
動画に時間を割くことも
なかなか出来なかったんですけど
9月とか８月とかもなかなかね
まあようやく終わったんで
もう少しちょっとやることがあるんで
それが終わり次第
やっと東京をおさらばして
静岡に帰らさせて頂きます
というわけでこれからなんですけども
いつもどおり普通のメインチャンネルに戻ります
ちゃんと力を入れてメインチャンネルも
作って行けると思うので
いつもどおり暇つぶしに動画を見てくれると
ありがたいと思っております！
８月全部と９月全部居たんで２か月位
ずっと東京にいたんですけど
なかなかねぇ
仕事面ではすごい移動が楽だったんですけど
動画的に言うとすごいなんかね
外で撮りにくかったなって感じです
人も多いし
あぁん\\すごい汗かいちゃった
まあなかなか思いどおりに
この部屋もうねちょっとあれなんすよ
なにか爆発させようと思ってもしちゃダメな感じだし
なんか僕が暴れるに至る場所でもないし
ちょっとやりずらい面も結構あったし
そもそも物がすくねぇし
まぁなかなか不便なことが多かったんですけども
まぁそれもそれで東京で楽しかったと思っております
て言うわけで多分なんですけど
もう1週間しないうちに静岡に帰ると思うんで
静岡に帰ってからはいつもどおり通常運転で
頑張ろうと思っておりますので
またよろしくお願いします
なかなかねえ
何やってんだこいつと思われる事が
多かったと思うんですよ
Twitterにも全然出てこねぇし（泣）
動画もあげねぇし（泣）
サブだけは無駄にあげてるしみたいな
ひとまず忙しいのは終わりましたので
これにて東京編は終了して
東京バイバイして
静岡に帰って
またいつもどおり頑張っていければいいなと
思っております
まぁそんな感じで現状報告です
東京ねぇ～いつか住むのかなと思いますね
東京来ることが
結局多いんで
結局また静岡に帰って東京に来なきゃいけない
ってことが増えるとまたちょっと大変なので
いつかは東京に行かなきゃいけないのかなぁとか
東京に住んでみて移動が楽だなっていうのも思ったし
今回は２か月しか居なかったんで
仮でばっと来てばっとなんかやっちゃったんですけど
ちゃんと住むことも考えないといけないのかなとか
思った
２か月間でした
まあとりあえずほんまに
し☆ず☆お☆か☆帰りたい！
そんで遊戯王したいわ！！
あ、ホント
遊戯王まじ２か月間我慢してましたからね
病気（ドヤア）
遊戯王まじ２か月間しませんでしたからね
あちょっとしたけど
そこは........
ほめてください(｀･ω･´)
動画、メインチャンネル、頑張っていこうと思います
それでは皆のしゅうまたお会いしよう
ばいばい
あ、日本のポケモン図鑑あと２匹で終わります
ED　♪～
字幕機能を見てくださり
ありがとうございました
!(^^)!